[Música]
ah
aquí comienza el debate de france 24 soy
ángela gómez y los acompaño en esta
emisión para hablar del giro de política
de eeuu o frente a cuba y venezuela en
el caso cubano el gobierno de joe biden
revivió las actividades consulares
enfocado en la reunificación familiar
además de la reactivación de vuelos
directos a varias ciudades de la isla y
la suspensión del límite de mil dólares
por trimestre a las remesas aquí en
resumen
la administración de joe biden dio
marcha atrás algunas medidas contra
cuba' impulsadas por donald trump el
restablecimiento de los vuelos
comerciales a toda la isla levantar el
límite de 1000 dólares por trimestre en
remesas y restablecer el programa de
reunificación familiar que fijaba en
20.000 la emisión de visas por año para
ciudadanos cubanos
con estas acciones pretendemos apoyar
las aspiraciones de libertad de los
cubanos y mayores oportunidades
económicas para que puedan llevar una
vida exitosa en su hogar seguimos
pidiendo el gobierno cubano que libere
de inmediato a los presos políticos que
respeten las libertades fundamentales
del pueblo cubano y que permita que el
pueblo cubano determine su propio futuro
el gobierno cubano no considera que sean
cambios significativos
anuncios del gobierno de eeuu es un paso
limitado en dirección correcta la
decisión no modifica el bloqueo la
inclusión fraudulenta en la lista de
países patrocinadores del terrorismo ni
la mayoría de medidas coercitivas de
máxima presión de trump que aún suprime
al pueblo cubano
por su parte de algunos ciudadanos en la
isla han recibido con beneplácito los
anuncios es una buena oportunidad
realmente que se está dando ahora mismo
al pueblo de cuba ya que
por esa medida se ha basado un trabajo
terrible hemos pasado 20 mil vicisitudes
durante su campaña electoral joe biden
prometió avanzar en las relaciones con
la habana tal y como lo hizo en su
momento el ex presidente barack obama de
quien bardem fue fórmula
vicepresidencial pero que se vieron
deterioradas con el arribo de trump a la
oficina oval estas medidas llegan casi
cuatro semanas después de que se
realizara el primer diálogo de alto
nivel entre ambos países y donde la
migración fue el tema principal más de
115.000 cubanos han llegado a eeuu desde
enero hasta abril a través de la
frontera con méxico según el instituto
nacional de migración mexicano
en el caso de venezuela washington
relajó algunas sanciones dando permiso a
la multinacional chevron para negociar
con el país caribeño futuras actividades
petroleras tras dos castigos que en 2019
buscaron apoyar a juan guaidó y su
llamado gobierno interino ahora vayan a
esperar revivir los diálogos entre el
socialismo y la oposición a través de
estas concesiones
el gobierno bolivariano de venezuela ha
verificado y confirmado las noticias
publicadas en el sentido de que los eeuu
de américa ha autorizado a empresas
petroleras estadounidenses y europeas
para que negocien y reinicien
operaciones en venezuela venezuela
aspira a que estas decisiones de los
eeuu de américa
inicien el camino para el levantamiento
absoluto de las sanciones ilícitas que
afectan a todo nuestro pueblo
para este debate dos puntos de vista se
conectan con france 24 julio ceiling
estratega republicano politólogo y
director de patria de martí se encuentra
en la ciudad de miami florida en eeuu
también está con nosotros solo ningún
bin era analista político estratega
demócrata y consultor internacional
también es diplomático norteamericano
quien se encuentra en washington y
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en el debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas lo pueden
hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook
instagram y twitter estamos como francia
de 24 raya al piso s y les recuerdo que
nuestra etiqueta de ese numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos sus comentarios
y comenzamos cómo se beneficia eeuu de
un acercamiento a venezuela queda al
final demostrado que las sanciones
contra este país no funcionaron y julio
comienzo con ustedes bienvenido
un placer
a estar contigo y con todo el equipo de
france 24 en los eeuu otros beneficios
para nada o sea vemos una gran
contradicción en por un lado una
política
moral enfocada a ayudar la democracia y
combatir el despotismo en europa en el
apoyo craneal y sin embargo por otro
lado vemos un acercamiento con el
dictador que dicho sea de paso son
íntimos aliados del dictador putin como
ese cuba comunista y la dictadura en
venezuela de modo de que los eeuu en
ningún sentido
se beneficia y está ejerciendo una doble
moral que precisamente envía mensajes es
sumamente equivocados y demuestre que no
hay ninguna brújula moral en la política
exterior de la actual administración
bueno la ourense la misma pregunta para
usted desde ese momento de que la casa
blanca de empiece a dar muestras de una
política diferente después de sanciones
en 2019 que no han cambiado realmente la
situación política de venezuela
sí muchas gracias a nada de gracias a
france 24 para esta invitación yo creo
que claramente el propósito de esas esas
medidas que son muy menores no son muy
significativos pero son como zanahorias
para traer al gobierno del interés
maduro a la mesa de negociaciones y
ojalá llegar a un acuerdo político
diplomático para resolver la crisis allá
entonces y estas esas medidas fueron
pedidos por la oposición la misma
oposición pidió un aflojamiento de la
presión económica para tratar de abrir
camino a una regulación de negociaciones
ahora hay dos otros temas que son muy
importantes y que juegan tanto con
venezuela como cuba
y el primero es la migración esparció se
está viendo una migración desde
venezuela y cuba que está alzando
tremendamente y tiene muy preocupada el
gobierno de perder de país por su
vulnerabilidad en las elecciones y poner
habilidad doméstica también viene a la
cumbre de las américas en los ángeles en
16 a 10 en cuando muchos países
importantes han declarado que no van a
participar si no está incluido venezuela
nicaragua lo más importante de ellos
siendo
méxico entonces también el gobierno está
buscando un camino para llegar a un
entendimiento
por lo menos para que participan estos
países importantes en los ángeles bueno
y de eso vamos a hablar en un momento
vamos a ir abordando tema por tema ahora
mismo quisiera que nos quedáramos en el
tema de los diálogos porque en todo caso
se ha manejado con bastante hermetismo
por parte de la casa blanca este nuevo
acercamiento con venezuela se han visto
reuniones de diplomáticos
un leve levantamiento de las sanciones
son muchas de las más fuertes que fueron
impuestas en el 2019 pero joe biden
asegura que eso no implica que va a
haber más ganancias o que va a haber
ingresos para el gobierno de nicolás
maduro que gana venezuela y que gana
eeuu en este caso para usted lores
bueno yo creo que los estados unidos y
la oposición también en vélez venezuela
ganamos si esto es suficiente para traer
a un nuevo nuevas negociaciones
para resolver el crisis
es un medida muy menor se habrán basado
en esto sobran tiene el derecho de
empezar a negociar no es ninguno no es
nada más de ahí entonces es muy menor
pero es significativo simbólicamente
para venezuela yo creo que sí es muy
importante porque están han vivido una
crisis económica tremendo por por años y
estas sanciones han pegado muy duro
al pueblo de venezuela más que todos los
líderes de venezuela nos están sufriendo
este pueblo que ha sufrido más que
cualquier entonces esto piensen que es
un camino de abrir poquito sus mercados
de petróleo y también para tener más
legitimidad para la administración y eso
es un riesgo para el gobierno de paz no
hay duda que si está ofreciendo un
poquito de ayuda a legitimar la
menstruación de negros maduro ese puede
ser un paso poquito delicado bueno y del
otro lado de la otra arista julio usted
cree que tienen algún futuro estos
movimientos que podrían permitir
realmente que se reactiven de forma
productiva los diálogos en venezuela
usted cree que gana algo eeuu si se
logra reactivar el diálogo entre la
oposición muy dividida en el país y el
del socialismo representado hoy por
nicolás maduro
se hace un grandes favor a la causa de
la libertad y la democracia
cuando se confunden
conceptos básicos y se da a entender un
régimen dictatorial por el país o sea
decir una medida contra cuba o una
medida contra venezuela no no no una
medida contra la dictadura
castrocomunista una medida contra el el
mal turismo socialista o sea en estos
regímenes son no representan a su pueblo
no son los líderes soberanos del país
entonces eso es muy importante mantener
en cuenta porque se establece una
equivalencia
inexistente entre el régimen dictatorial
que ellos supongo que todos estamos de
acuerdo que lo que hay en cuba lo que
hay en venezuela es una dictadura
segundo
es incierto y la oposición venezolana de
forma unísono está viviendo un diálogo
con la dictadura
de nicolás maduro no es el caso que lo
pida
juan guaidó no quiere decir que lo es de
una forma singular la
oposición recordemos que sí es cierto lo
que ha publicado
john boulting el ex ministro de
presidente de trump pues habían miembros
de la oposición que directamente no
querían que los estados unidos y otros
aliados democráticos de la región
tomaran una medida rescatadora para
liberar a venezuela de la dictadura
socialista que está en el poder que no
es nada más que una colonia de cuba
comunista dicho sea de paso bueno es que
julio definitivamente no hay muchísima
claridad sobre lo que está pasando en
estas relaciones de eeuu y venezuela con
este nuevo enfoque que le está
entregando joe biden creería yo que
tenemos que esperar avanzan un poco más
las cosas a que haya un mayor desarrollo
para entender realmente pues para dónde
van estas estos intentos de revivir las
negociaciones pero es que tienen el
problema angela es que hay que entender
el modelo dictatorial dictatorial que
está en el poder en venezuela es el
prototipo que surgió a raíz del foro de
sao paulo tras la caída del comunismo
soviético esto fue un invento del
difunto tirano fidel castro la idea era
ya no habían los recursos para seguir en
la lucha armada para llegar al poder y
había que cambiar la metodología y una
de ellas era bueno competir en
elecciones competitivas democráticas una
vez que llegaban al poder empezar a
desmantelar el orden democrático y
mantener un simulacro de una democracia
o sea podemos estar de acuerdo que hugo
chávez ganó en las primeras elecciones
para a partir de ahí es un debate serio
igual que es el caso en nicaragua y
podemos añadir bolivia también de modo
de qué
un diálogo
con un poder político que está el
renegado abrirse los espacios necesarios
que son precondiciones para realmente
poder poner el poder político en un
entorno competitivo entre fuerzas
lugares del país venezuela está muy
distante de hacer eso de modo de que un
diálogo es simple y llanamente un
mecanismo para entretenerlos eeuu buscar
recursos que quien más beneficia es al
poder político el problema de la miseria
crónica que hay en venezuela y en cuba
comunista es sistémica el problema claro
y que está o sea dirigido desde el poder
político y usaban las cosas que tendrían
que hacer si quisieran mejorar su
economía no lo hacen por miedo a perder
el poder político bueno estamos hablando
precisamente de ideología lawrence y
julio y en el espíritu de seguir
enriqueciendo pues el debate pues vamos
a conversar entonces ahora del otro
protagonista de esta historia que es
hécuba y este cambio de restricciones de
los eeuu lawrence
la crisis migratoria usted la mencionaba
brevemente al inicio de este debate esa
es la respuesta a la nueva política
estadounidense frente a la isla
bueno eso es parte de la situación con
cuba igual con venezuela a partir de las
situaciones relacionados por la
migración y ha subido y parte y también
está relacionado con la misma cosa de
cumbre de las américas pero si hay
diferencias grandes está bien y después
de un palacio review desde que empezó yo
bailé en el gobierno hicieron un palacio
review y ahora decidieron que era tiempo
de empezar a aflojar poquito las
sanciones muy duros que habían puesto
por trump ahora las sanciones contra
cuba estamos en juego con julio que tuvo
es una indicador a que el gobierno
representa el pueblo tampoco en
venezuela porque no estamos de acuerdo
es cómo cambia la situación en cuba
tenemos 60 años de un embargo económico
y no ha hecho nada para mejorar la
situación en la isla entonces el mismo
gobierno cubano está contento con el
barco porque
utilicen el embargo para justificar sus
medidas antidemocráticas
entonces la idea de empezar así con este
afloramiento es ofrecer algo con las
remesas con el sector privado que estaba
creciendo cuando obama dejó de de mejor
poder el sector privado cubano pequeños
empresarios estaban creciendo con apoyo
de los eeuu yo fui encargado de negocios
en nuestra embajada en la habana durante
varios meses el primer año del
precedente chrome y yo vi como las
sanciones que impuso dentro me empezó a
dañar no al gobierno cubano sino el
pueblo cubano entonces yo creo que la
política de baile es esto tiene el mismo
meta de la democratización de la isla la
cuestión es cómo llegar a ese punto y
también cómo mejorar la situación en la
isla para él cubano comunicore y como
eso afecta hacia el interior del país
podemos estar de acuerdo los tres en que
efectivamente estamos volviendo con este
nuevo gobierno donde se quedó la
política cuando barack obama estaba en
el poder yo wyden como su vicepresidente
ahora presidente del país pues se
retorna a este camino de suavizar las
restricciones y de lo dice usted
lawrence apoyar al pueblo cubano
mientras tanto se anuncian los planes de
bloqueo de byd en el que quería levantar
el título 42 esa medida polémica del ex
presidente de donald trump que se escudó
en la pandemia y que permitió la
expulsión de indocumentados de la
frontera sin que se les tramitará su
solicitud de asilo en este momento la
demanda de los estados órgano diciendo
que se volcaría muchísimo mayor de las
migraciones si es que se levanta este
título 42 pero entonces les pregunto a
los dos necesitaba ir en esta medida con
cuba para mostrar que si está frenando
los ingresos ilegales y para presentar
las cifras de mejora en migración julio
gracias por la concesión de que hay una
dictadura en cuba comunista y en
venezuela ahora
hay dos visiones completamente
diferentes de la realidad cubana primero
cuando no hay una sociedad civil no
existe en la sociedad
existe un simulacro de una sociedad
civil y esto es muy importante entender
porque relaciones de que se basan en
comercio con un medio medio para mejorar
con regímenes de dominación total como
el que existe en cuba solo terminan
fortaleciendo
a la dictadura china y vietnam son
ejemplos de esa política fracasada y el
embargo es cierto que lleva seis décadas
pero la misma vez nos ha aplicado de una
forma coherente y el argumento de que no
ha funcionado podemos decir también de
que hace más de treinta y pico de años
que no ha funcionado la apertura con
comunista recordemos que desde los años
90 la inversión extranjera en cuba los
turistas bajan cuba cuba comunista tenía
este una economía dolarizada o sea que
ni pocos países de américa les dinero lo
han hecho de modo de que el argumento de
lo que funciona no funciona trabaja de
ambos de ambos lados la realidad es que
en cuba se es un capitalismo de estado
en otras palabras 75% de la economía
cubana está en manos de empresas
estatales
llevadas a cabo dirigidas por las
fuerzas armadas en el sector turístico
el por cierto es más de un 90% es ser un
empresario en cuba comunista requiere
una conducta domesticada en cuanto a los
parámetros políticos aquí tenemos un
caso que está guardando la distancia
como en china la mayoría de los miembros
del partido comunista chino son
empresarios hay una razón por eso por
china comunista ha logrado establecer
para los claves al éxito y los accesos a
crédito y facilitar para exportar y
poder producir tener un acercamiento con
el régimen dictatorial lo mismo ocurre
en cuba quienes más se han beneficiado
del intercambio los eeuu han sido de las
empresas
estatales como gais
que han engordado sus filas precisamente
por esto y la noción de que el turismo
otra falsedad es china ha sido el
segundo antes de la pandemia el segundo
en lugar del turista del mundo y los
turistas han llevado la democracia a
china de modo de que en regímenes
autoritarios
si hay un argumento corea del sur
taiwán brasil grecia son ejemplos
yo lo entiendo hay una realidad que no
podemos eludir y es que durante la
pandemia por ejemplo china cerró
completamente sus puertas a los viajes
es hasta este momento que se ha vuelto a
abrir muy lentamente y bueno tenemos
como resultado de su política kobe cero
con esta mínima apertura pues que han
aumentado los casos ahora el caso de la
isla pues es un caso en el que el
turismo era vital es tan vital que en
este momento la gente muere de hambre en
la habana y en las ciudades cubanas pero
quisiera que no nos quedáramos demasiado
en esto para que podamos avanzar y
seguro que mi siguiente pregunta le va a
interesar también mucho julio porque
porque aquí quiero preguntar cómo le va
a cobrar el congreso de eeuu a byd en
esta nueva apuesta que está haciendo por
cuba y por venezuela porque el congreso
de todas maneras cobra duro no todos los
demócratas están en todo caso de acuerdo
con esta nueva política de relajación
ante los dos países que lo han dicho
ustedes dos son considerados por el
gobierno norteamericano como dictaduras
y en este caso quisiera empezar por
usted la rencilla vas a darle la palabra
nuevamente julio
bueno él
y la realidad es que especialmente con
cuba es más política doméstica que
política exterior y ha sido eso casi
siempre entonces lo que hace los estados
unidos con cuba tiene mucho enfoque en
el impacto dentro de los eeuu y en este
año es un año de elecciones entonces es
aún más prominente esta situación que
éste tiene mucho con enfoque en las
elecciones de noviembre para la
administración de baile el piensa y los
piensa que se pueden bajar la
inmigración irregular y aumentar y tener
bajo control la inmigración regular
puede mejorar su situación electoral y
por otro lado al lado de los
republicanos van a tratar de
especialmente los publicanos en el
congreso y los que están en campaña para
tratar de castigar a iovine por estas
aperturas entonces va a ser una batalla
entre los dos
cuando yo bailo como donald trump como
todos los presidentes han hecho esas
medidas bajo órdenes ejecutivos porque
el congreso
básicamente no puede no puede muy
difícil para el congreso entre pedir
cuando bajo órdenes ejecutivos del mismo
presidente acs es bajo del ejecutivo
porque sabe que el congreso está
congelada en cuanto a la legislación
pertinente la el embargo es una
legislación quitar los seriales quería
un voto del congreso y los demócratas
saben que no tienen los votos para
quitar embargo es por esa razón tanto
barack obama como yo bailé está actuando
bajo órdenes ejecutivos que están dentro
de su poder y en su pero este tema va a
ser si con travis o lo mismo y es porque
el congreso está muy conectado muy
difícil el congreso actúa en esa manera
entonces y este va a ser una cuestión de
campaña especialmente la florida es un
tema muy poderoso pero en otras partes
también donde hay
a cubano-americanos
tienen un poder político tanto poder
económico y están muy activos la
población hispana y la población cubana
son muy relevantes en el país cada día
más eso es innegable y dicho esto pues
julio cuál es su opinión
tu ángel torres-- tocar un punto muy
importante que quiero volver a él en
cuanto a lo que es la inmigración y el
impacto en las en las elecciones por hay
que estar claro que el turismo
tomando en cuenta que las empresas
castristas controlan el sector turístico
sobre todo el 90% de la economía el
turismo no beneficia básicamente en nada
al pueblo cubano las protestas masivas
del 11 de julio el año pasado donde
cientos de miles de cubanos salieron a
protestar espontáneamente
+72 localizadas localidades a través de
la isla exigirá la libertad exigen el
fin del dominio comunista no pedían
visas para salir nos pedían acceso a los
productos americanos no podían turistas
y creo que ahí está la clave y de la
forma en que está constituido en la
economía cubana en la actualidad toda
esa transferencia de riqueza es más el
presidente bailén acaba de autorizar el
10 de mayo que probablemente va a ser
retado en las cortes una inversión
extranjera directa de un de inversores
estadounidenses a una compañía cubana en
otras palabras compañía cubana estamos
hablando una compañía estatal porque en
cuba comunista repito en la economía
está abdominal de lo que se dice son lo
que se ese es el capitalismo de estado
de modo de que esto es supongo que va a
ser retado en las cortes viola el acto
libertad pero la suposición de que por
medio de entre cambio comercial van a
mejorar la condición de vida de los
cubanos es una falacia la inmigración es
muy importante y podemos decir él les
mencioné el 11 de julio del año pasado
que fue pues un levantamiento popular
pacífico en cuba bueno unos meses
después en noviembre la dictadura
castrista negocia con nicaragua la libre
salida de todos los guantes quieren
salir por nicaragua también negoció con
méxico con el gobierno de lópez obrador
de que los cuernos fueran molestados en
su travesía hacia los eeuu en otras
palabras la inmigración el éxodo como
arma ha sido utilizado por la dictadura
comunista grabada en más de cuatro
ocasiones y eso es lo que está
utilizando y sin duda esto pone en estos
acuerdos en lawrence en una presión
extraordinaria en la administración de
ellos va en la reunión los otros días de
representantes de la dictadura de la
dictadura cubana washington en efecto
fue para hacer las exigencias que
estamos viendo ahora bien
poniéndose en vigencia y consideró que
el presidente valentín ya da por hecho
que la florida la va a perder como tú
bien mencionaste es ángela por el voto
no sólo de cubanos de venezolanos de
nicaragüenses de bolivianos de
colombianos que están huyendo de la
posibilidad de que caiga un candidato de
la izquierda radical en el poder
entonces estamos viendo
que consideramos que el presidente ya
dio por hecho que la flor está perdida
el propio con el senador
para menéndez pues ha criticado
fuertemente estas acciones de el
presidente bain pero hay otros estados
que la inmigración
en la frontera la tragedia de la
frontera sur puede repercutir yo creo
que es hacia eso lo que es donde está
apuntalando
la administración actual para tratar de
rescatar al menos otros estados que
pueden formar parte del tsunami
republicano que se espera en noviembre
pues sí mire en el caso de colombia le
tendría que refutar que después es
diferente la naturaleza que usted cita
para una posible migración que exista y
bueno sobre eso habrá que ver y aquí
estaremos en france24 para reportarlo
para nuestro siguiente tema quisiera
continuar primero con ustedes julio
solamente porque el ourense de ya lo
mencionó desde su primera intervención y
es que cuesta creer que los últimos
movimientos de eeuu son casualidades
cuando estamos precisamente en la
antesala de la cumbre de las américas y
aquí la pregunta para los dos está
cediendo la casa blanca ante esta
presión que tanto hemos hablado en este
caso de los países que amenazan con no
asistir porque ya varios latinos fueron
los que sentaron la voz de protesta lo
hicieron méxico uno de los socios
comerciales más importantes de eeuu
guatemala bolivia honduras los miembros
del caricom estos países de
centroamérica además que pues tienen
tantos negocios y tantos que discutir
con eeuu por la migración ilegal y
argentina y chile aunque ya mostrar un
desacuerdo con que venezuela y cuba no
puedan estar presentes entonces cuál es
su opinión sobre todo esto julio como no
recordemos que la cura de las américas
es una extensión de la organización de
estados américanos emplearse la carta
fundacional de la oea
básicamente establece la democracia como
el como el sistema exclusivo de el
órgano el sentar dictadores al lado de
presidentes democráticamente elegidos es
un gran error que sólo sirve al
despotismo continental de modo de que si
estos países que todos mencionados que
todos tienen gobiernos que de una forma
u otra o simpatizan y tienen relaciones
muy estrechas con el castrocomunismo y
la dictadura en venezuela pues si no
quieren asistir a los estados unidos
mira si algo ha demostrado
en la guerra
en craneal a agresión rusa es la
inutilidad de organismo como la naciones
unidas como bien dijo el presidente
excelentes que porque si no puede
resolver un conflicto porque tienen el
bloqueo de uno de los actores del mal
eso es resultado de esa equivalencia
falsa y errada de tener dictadores al
lado demócratas las américas no deben
repetir ese error y si debe ser un club
exclusivo para regímenes democráticos y
si alguna democracia por tener
relaciones
estrechas con dictaduras en el
continente no quiere asistir a ellos
pero se envía un terrible mensaje el
mensaje que envió el subsecretario en
métodos
en una entrevista donde dijo que no iban
a ser invitados es el correcto
los eeuu no debería de quebrarse ante el
chantaje de países que son regímenes de
nuevo que tienen apegos emocionales e
ideológicos con dictaduras que cometen
crímenes de lesa humanidad y yo creo que
en eso estamos todos de acuerdo bueno
aunque usted está diciendo lo que sería
coherente con el manejo histórico que ha
dado pues eeuu a estos temas y
principalmente a cuba y a venezuela la
prensa ahora quisiera preguntarle a
usted ya hablando en la realidad pues yo
no sé qué tanto sea allá de ellos porque
es que esta es la cumbre de las américas
y estamos hablando de la influencia de
los eeuu con américa latina' con sus
socios comerciales con una región del
mundo que está en pleno auge y que pues
es el centro y el polo de explotaciones
que espera por supuesto eeuu usted cómo
ve la posición de joe biden en este
momento entre la espada y la pared con
países que dicen que no van y buscando
la posibilidad de que haya sino bien
representación oficial del país si
algunos enviados para hablar en nombre
por ejemplo de cubano eso no está
confirmado hay que decirlo también
si todavía no han confirmado aunque lo
que digo leo es correcto ella y dentro
de las embajadas ya han ido a los
gobiernos anunciando que en méxico ni
venezuela ni cuba nicaragua iba a ser
invitados entonces y cogieron por
sorpresa la resistencia de ese
asunto la administración de iovine y
ahora están tratando de rescatar la
cumbre porque saben especialmente si
lópez obrador de méxico no viene bien se
causa en muchos otros países en resistir
la invitación esto puede ser muy grave
para el éxito de la cumbre ahora yo no
creo que van a ceder porque creo que es
muy difícil ahora que lo que han
anunciado subsecretario de coss y otros
y también lo que dicen es correcto que
la carta democrática de su principal muy
importante para la cumbre y para la oea
pero yo creo que están tratando de
rare unas medidas para suave ser la
posición duro de ambos y otros jefes de
estado es lo que está tratando de
hacerse estamos trabajando govern a
suelo en cuba estamos disponibles a
negociar con los países a encontrar
otras maneras de detener nuestras
relaciones en la esperanza que eso es
suficiente para justificar ahora que
hablo y los otros habéis estado van a
cambiar su posición es muy difícil y es
muy de última hora pero eso es lo que
tiene que hacer yo no veo factible que
ellos van a dejar y mientras nicolás
maduro que tiene una acusación a los
colores de los eeuu para lavado de plata
y que oficialmente todavía no
reconocemos ser como el el presente
legítimo es casi imposible que permiten
y muy difícil políticamente
invitar a 10 cáner entonces yo no veo
factible una invitación ese servicio
estado la administración está tratando
de respetar la cumbre con otros medidas
y otros argumentos para los jefes de
estado que tienen problemas pues ahora
que veré si este tono conciliatorio que
está estrenando eeuu con el gobierno de
joe biden es realmente call al ourense
ya nos quedan pocos minutos sobre para
llegar al final del programa y por eso
les quiero pedir a los dos por favor
concretamente ya para finalizar este
debate porque sí y porque no está bien o
mal esta nueva postura de eeuu de frente
a venezuela y frente a cuba comienzo con
ustedes lawrence y finalizó con julio
bueno yo creo que definitivamente con
cuba es una medida importante y
necesario y yo creo que es la hora de
hacer más e ir más allá para beneficio
del pueblo cubano aunque políticamente
no creo que vaya tiene la capital
política hacerlo con venezuela es más
delicado ellos están haciendo como baby
step espacios pequeños para tratar de
crear un nuevo momento hacían
negociaciones yo veo esto como con menos
probabilidad de éxito pero es un
esfuerzo que con el apoyo de algunos de
la oposición sino completamente la
oposición venezolano ellos sintieron que
tenían el respaldo del pueblo en
venezuela hacer estas cosas
en julio
gracias a ti france 24 y al horno por la
oportunidad de tocar un tema tan
importante
yo creo que es el enfoque es
y tratar de facilitar bien hacia la
democratización esto es la vía
equivocada tomando en cuenta el sistema
que se está tratando de producir el
cambio si no hay una sociedad civil si
lo que se ejerce es el capitalismo de
estado una transferencia de riqueza
solamente va a fortalecer al poder
político y es abrir las avenidas la
avenida es para la domesticación una
china tropical
no la queremos en en cuba ni tampoco
para venezuela en los eeuu debería de
estar
precisamente buscando avenidas para
producir cambios de regímenes si el
principio de las sanciones es vital para
combatir la dictadura de vladimir putin
también debe ser vital para combatir la
dictadura en cuba en venezuela y en
nicaragua
pues bien el agradecimiento realmente es
para ustedes por un diálogo que fue
sincero que fue honesto que fue
respetuoso pero además que se mantuvo
fiel a las posturas políticas en eeuu y
pues que tienen ustedes también en sus
casas el agradecimiento también para
nuestros televidentes por estar una vez
más con nosotros aquí en el debate de
france 24 eran julio chilling estratega
republicano y lawrence gumbiner
estratega demócrata para ustedes sigan
con nosotros y más adelante volvemos con
más
[Música]